talk to me about the average
temperatures and how that's going to
affect our gas prices let me run through
it because there's quite a lot that's
obviously happened in the last few
months with gas price they've been
obviously very high uh for us consumers
but the wholesale markets which is where
that's affected well those prices have
been yo-yoing quite a lot and if I just
show you what's going on there we can
probably kind of just about make it out
here this this is the higher this is
obviously the higher the wholesale
prices so this is what your your Energy
company is paying for for those prices
and what I wanted to focus on is that
recently look that line has gone up and
up and up and so that is that's
essentially kind of winter you know
that's a bit of the winter pressure
starting to come through here aside from
from everything else and if we just take
a step back and kind of remind ourselves
of what's going on here we get a sense
of why this is happening and the thing
to remember here is that obviously the
UK is there I'll put it in red but we
all really part of the European market
when it comes to gas and why is that is
because if we zoom in there are these
interconnectors connecting the UK and
the rest of Europe where we get a lot of
our gas from and that really matters
because when you look at kind of where
that European gas has actually come from
well here is this is a kind of bar
representing all of Europe's gas coming
in recently that was last year okay and
if I break it down you get a sense of
where the issue here is okay so you've
got for instance I'll kind of take that
bar and show you that's that's
production so that's basically gas
that's coming out of the North Sea gas
coming out of the Netherlands uh there
you've got Norway like a lot of the gas
at the moment that we're getting in
Europe uh comes from Norway we've split
that out there and then really the big
one Russia and that's the real question
mark here okay if we take that bar there
so that's part of the constituent Parts
this is where Europe gets its gas from
including the UK at the moment what
about Russia because when you look at
that total of gas like I say this is
last year this is the total you
basically have to delete that or kind of
assume what are you going to do without
rush and gas and actually so much of the
story that we are going through right
now as a nation in the UK and of course
in Europe as well is about that Gap you
know how do we make that good because so
much of our Lives depend on that and
also businesses as well so so that is
the story kind of last year and then if
we roll onto kind of where we are now so
here's where we are just in the last few
months Russia still there but you saw it
was really big before now it's tiny it's
about kind of eight billion it's down by
uh 81
um the interesting thing that's got
bigger is LNG what's LNG is liquefied
natural gas and that basically is the
gas that comes in on ships okay so
you've got all of these different kind
of terminals around Europe and what you
can probably make out is quite a lot of
them are there in the UK and the upshot
of that is a lot of gas comes over uh
from overseas and recently we've heard
that the US is hoping to send mortar to
us we put past it through the UK and
then it goes through those pipes I was
showing you a second ago into Europe so
that's helped to kind of push up the
amount of gas LNG coming into the
continent but the big thing really here
is this total demand remember that was
up at about 85 before that's gone down
so we are consuming less gas across
Europe in recent months but why is that
it comes back to what you're saying a
second here it comes back to the fact
that it hasn't really been that cold in
recent months you know if you look this
is the kind of showing you the Max and
the men the the range of temperatures
over the last kind of decade and a half
or a couple of decades and where we are
this year look at that red line it's
quite close to the maximum so we just
haven't been having the heating on as
much in recent months but of course now
we've all noticed it is very cold in the
last few days and the question is what
happens next and if we get down there
then we have to turn the heating on a
bit more businesses potentially have to
consume more the other thing by the way
that that is worth noting here because
it comes into the UK story is
across in Europe they've been pumping a
lot of their gas into storage so they've
got all of these storage places Old Salt
Caverns old gas Fields you put the gas
in there and then hopefully you can use
it when you know God forbid something
happens to Russian gas coming across
from Ukraine which it might well do but
look where the UK is it has much less
storage than most other countries in
Europe look Germany Italy Netherlands
those are the big ones so they have all
the storage we don't have much storage
which begs the question of you know what
happens if get things get really cold in
Winter and the answer to that this is
where things get a little bit kind of
you know nerve-wracking because back in
the past what this is showing you is
basically this is gas going out of the
UK to Europe anything above the line
anything below the line is stuff coming
into the UK from Europe and you can see
when it's winter gas comes from Europe
to the UK when it's summer gas goes out
of the UK into Europe but recently we've
had record exports and here's the really
big question no one knows what's going
to happen in the next few months if it
gets really cold can we still rely on
those inflows coming across from Europe
all of which is why kind of long story
short it it comes back to whether
there's going to be gas that's going to
flow from those interconnectors into
Europe into the UK from Europe
and here's the final chart sorry I know
there's been loads of charts here but
this is kind of you know the big story
it's a bit of a recap because we haven't
done this for a while that's the UK gas
price okay I'm going to show you the
European gas price in the last few
months the European gas price for day
ahead delivery has been higher than the
UK because we've had all that liquefied
natural gas coming in now those two
lines are converging and we could over
the next few months potentially see the
UK price going high while the European
one stays low because they have all that
storage and so it's one of those moments
I think that's why it's worth talking
about today it's not just about
temperature although this is affected by
temperature it's about the fact that no
one's entirely sure how this Market's
going to function over the course of the
next few months which of course raises
questions about what's going to happen
to gas prices we've got the cap at the
moment but what happens those wholesale
prices and then what happens to gas
prices afterwards so it's quite kind of
nervy moment for everyone yeah nervy
moment as as you said we enter into that
culture now that could last for the next
few weeks potentially into January Ed
thank you very much Ed Conway bringing
the wider picture to that story for us
this afternoon thank you